مصر القديمه كانت متوهجه تغريده
للملياردير الامريكيه على تويتر متفاعلا
مع مقطع قصير لبعض الدندره الذي يقع في
محافظه قنا المصريه
تسعه ملايين قراءه ومشاهده بعدها تلقى مصر
دعوات من شخصيه عامه لزياره مصر لكن ليست
التغريده الاولى عن ارض الكنانه في 2020
كتب تغريده ساخره اثارت الجدل يقول فيها
ان الفضائيين هم من بنوا الاهرامات وقتها
تلقى دعوه من رانيا المشاط وزيره العلاقات
الدوليه تدعوا لاكتشاف والاستكشاف
الاهرامات من بلد الاهرامات
ماسك موسم شتاوي مصر حيث ارتفعت نسب
بالاشغال في فنادق البحر الاحمر والاقصر
ما بين 80 و100% خلال العام الجاري يترقب
سياح لا لافتتاح المتحف المصري الكبير
اكبر متحف في العالم المخصص لحضاره واحده
[موسيقى]
من القاهره ومن خلف الاهرامات تحديدا تنضم
الينا مراسله صباح العربيه
صباحك اهلا بك يا سمر كيف تفعل المصريون
اول مع تغريدات الى مصر
صباح الخير يا سهام صباح الخير يا نادين
المصريين تفاعلوا جدا مع
تغريده الون ماسك منهم مثلا الوزيره رانيا
المشاط قالت له تعالى يلا زور مصر الفنان
محمد هنيدي الرجل الاعمال نجيب ساويرس
وطبعا عالم الاثار المصري زاهي دكتور زاهي
حواس اااه يعني التغريده حققت يمكن حد
الجمعه اللي فاتت حوالي 6 مليون مشاهده
همم التغريده دي كانت بناءا على فيديو
نزله همم احد السائحين ل- اا معبد دندره
في همم في مدينه قنا هاعرفكم عليه بعد
شويه همم الموقف ده يعني يمكن بيتماشى مع
حمله ترويجيه تقوم بها مصر همم منذ العام
الماضي همم على السوشيال ميديا اللي هي
فاوللد صن او اتبع الشمس همم وخصوصا مع
ارتفاع تكلفه الطاقه في عده دول في مصر مش
مساء يعني لسه الشمس رايحه من خمس دقائق
ده انت
بتتزامن مع هذه انا موجوده بس بدات دلوقتي
اتمطر شويه بس مش حد من خمس دقائق كانت
الشمس ساطعه همم فعلا السنه الاخرانيه
كانت يعني 2022
شاهدت عوده ممكن اا او الرابط لعوده
لاعداد السياحه في فتره ما قبل الكرونه
يعني تقريبا وصل عدد السائحين همم 12 همم
مليون زائر العامل الماضي اللي هو فين
2020 وهذا الشتاء يعني لسه ما اعلنش
الارقام بتاعته بس همم يعني مثلا في
الكريسماس والراس السنه كانت الفنادق
تقريبا همم كامله العكس طيب سمر يعني كلنا
حابين نعرف ما هو هذا المعبد يعني اتحدث
لماذا اثار كل هذا التفاعل
[موسيقى]
ما بدنا دار يمكن مش معروف قوي لان هو
موجود بالقرب من مدينه قنا في صعيد مصر
شمال الاقصر ولكنه من اجمل المعابد اللي
موجوده ومن اكثر المعابد اللي محتفظه
يعني بنقشها وبشكلها هو معبد عمرو 2500
سنه شويه في عصر البطاليه
للمعبوده حتحور وهي كانت ترمز
الجمال والامومه والحب اللي معبد ده كانوا
بيكون في اعياد دينيه
والفيديو اللي بيظهر همم السلالم اللي
منحوته داخل الصخر والصناديب دي كانت
بتقام فيها الاحتفالات الدينيه همم في
اعمده وفي اسقف عليها نقوش ملونه عليها
مناظر جميله جدا همم طبعا زي ما انتم
عارفين بيبقى اغلب السياحه بتروح سعيد مصر
بتروح الاقصر واسوان معابد الكرنك والاقصر
لكن معبد دندره يعتبر من اجمل المعابد
المصريه اه سمر مصر تنتظر الحدث الكبير
هذا العام هو افتتاح المتحف المصري الكبير
اعطينا فكره عن هذا المتحف والاستعدادات
الجديده
همم الاستعدادات على قاعده افتتاح الرسمي
للمتحف المصري الكبير ال- اا ال- ال-
المتحف ده يعني وضع همم حجر الاساس بتاعه
من 20 سنه تقريبا همم وتوقف لفتره بعد
الثوره ال- ال- البناء ورجع ثاني همم بقى
لهم سنتين بيستعدوا لهذا الحفل اللي
المفروض هيكون اسطوري همم في خلال سته
اشهر القادمه وهيستمر عده ايام هيحضره
زعماء وملوك من جميع انحاء العالم المتحف
ده على مساحه 117 فدان موجود هنا عند
الاهرامات وبيطل على الاهرامات همم هيكون
في حوالي 50,000 قطعه اثريه يمكن اهمها
لاول مره هتعرض المجموعه الكامله ل همم
اثار الملك توت عنخ امون حوالي 5000 قطعه
هتعرض كلها مع بعض وفي مجموعه همم والده
الملك خوفو مراكب الشمس يعني عدد كبير من
وايضا هناك معمل للترميم همم بالمتحف
وطبعا اساليب العرض هتبقى همم وفقه احدث
الاساليب صباح العربيه الحديثه سمر صباح
العربيه وفريق العربيه بانتظارك المره
المقبله من قنا وتحديدا من دندره
[موسيقى]